hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar roll of
sars kobe 2
serology in a vaccinated world i am
jennifer woods of labruz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diasoren
to learn more visit diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
david engman
md phd medallion
chairman emeritus of pathology
cedars-sinai medical center
visiting professor of pathology ucla
and retired professor of pathology at
northwestern university
you may now begin your presentation
everyone for joining today i'd like to
discuss
the role of sars kobe 2 serology in a
vaccinated world a very important
issue as we move through the end of the
pandemic hopefully and on to a post
vaccinated world the objectives of my
presentation
are as follows i'll first give a brief
update on
sars kobe 2 in the disease covet 19
review the current and emerging
applications for serology to this virus
discuss the variation among the
different vaccine types
with respect to three different major
issues
and finally talk about a new innovation
in serology
which involves the natural form of the
major
surface antigen spike protein as a
capture antigen for serologic diagnosis
first an update so remember
just very briefly one viral particle
can enter a host cell and through taking
over the host machinery
and providing some proteins of its own
can generate thousands of copies of the
virus from a single
infection cycle there are
multiple possible outcomes of infection
that's acquired through the inhalation
of droplets containing small amounts of
virus
about 40 percent of infected people have
no symptoms at all they're asymptomatic
forty to fifty percent have mild
symptoms
that do not require hospitalization
around twelve percent of infected people
globally
require hospitalization because they're
very ill with this infection
and three percent die of this infection
worldwide
and then a very interesting and unusual
and not very well understood
sequela of this abduction is called long
covid where one or more
symptoms of infection persist beyond six
months
after clearing the virus so this is
basically the four
different outcomes in a very simplified
way
sars kobe 2 is a perfect virus
it's perfect because it's easily
transmitted
it can be transmitted before symptoms
develop if they develop it all
and it only causes serious illness or
death in a low percentage of infected
people
this is what makes it so successful
in contrast its cousin sars cov1
which was circulating around 15 to 20
years ago was not perfect
it was too lethal it killed people
before they were able to transmit to
others
and transmission did not occur before
symptoms develop
so people once they develop symptoms
could sequester and then prevent
spread to others so this is the
difference between stars kobe 2 and 1.
at this point in time after this
pandemic
began in late 2019 and all the way to
the present time
we've had waves of virus that have hit
different parts of the world shown in
different colors
with the americas in yellow having its
surge
south east asia especially india is
having its surge now europe and green
surged some time ago
and at the very moment something between
seventy and thousand
seventy and 000 deaths per week are
still happening
with this pandemic so it's still
a major public health problem even as
much of the emer world emerges from this
epidemiological there have been 175 000
k
a million cases in the world with 3.8
million deaths
and what's interesting here is that that
represents 2.2
of the world population and the
mortality is 2.2 percent
of that 175 million in the united states
10 of our population
has been infected with about a 2
mortality rate
canada about four percent with one point
eight percent
in india 2.1
uh of the population is infected and
this number 1.3
is growing as the india cases
lead to deaths in a small number of
people there's still 130 000
cases here out of 432 000 new cases in
the world
now i should emphasize that in terms of
deaths
we still are losing 10 000
people per day
of this infection that's enough to fill
50 200 passenger jets per day
it's still a major problem
what about serology in a vaccinated
world
so we're skipping ahead beyond the basic
biology and epidemiology to the major
focus today first of all we need to get
the world vaccinated
at this point in time we're approaching
3
billion doses of vaccines that have been
administered on earth
with some countries in the darker color
here doing better
united states and canada china mongolia
and much of europe
but other areas not doing so well with
vaccine delivery
in the united states 44 are fully
vaccinated
53 percent have had at least one dose
canada is doing a little bit better with
at least one dose but 15
because many people haven't received
their second shot
and india is just getting started 15
with one dose four percent fully
vaccinated
and this is part of the reason that
we're seeing a big surge
of cases and deaths in india at the
moment
the comparison of where vaccines have
been done very well
and the current hot spots reveal some
very interesting things first of all
in south america there are many cases
going on right now
and the vaccinations have lagged a
little bit behind
what we see in north america europe and
and china whereas india
africa the african subcontinent is
relatively
unvaccinated and it's
it doesn't have lots of cases yet but
there's a great fear that these
cases are going to really skyrocket
before the vaccination
can be delivered effectively and that's
something that the
public health community is very
concerned about
how about the serology applications
i think about this and others do as well
as
five different buckets if you will
and we'll deal with these in turn one at
a time
the first is primary diagnosis of
infection
now most people are
diagnosed officially by rtpcr
or detection of viral rna in an upper
airway sample
and serology though is going to be
essential after viral clearance
because some people will be infected and
recovered
they may be have asymptomatic infection
not even be aware
of being infected and for those
people serology will be the way
to determine whether they have had a
primary
infection at some point in the past
because virus is no longer present after
they've cleared it
as you can see the rna and antigen
a peak after about seven days and then
go away sometime between two and four
weeks after infection
for most people but the antibody
response
igm in blue and igg arise and persist
and that igg antibody which persists
is what can be used to detect previous
infection
epidemiologic studies are largely done
through reporting
by various health departments based on
those rtpcr results to detect viral rna
but serology will be more important over
time
as this pandemic continues and
eventually resolves
measuring immunity in immunocompromised
individuals
who might not make a very strong
measurable immune response to infection
or to vaccination many studies
show that antibody and t cell responses
are blunted and i'll talk about this
more
later and we'll discuss this below
especially after we talk about immunity
to vaccination
evaluating plasma for convalescent
plasma therapy
this is where you administer plasma from
someone who's recovered or recovering
from infection
in hope that delivering those antibodies
to patients who have early infection
might help them recover more quickly
the problem is that these convalescent
plasma transfers have not worked very
well
and monoclonal antibody therapies have
not worked as well as hoped for either
as we'll discuss below the titers
of antibodies in vaccinated people are
much higher
than is seen in those who recovered from
infection and this gives rise to some
hope
that there's plasma from vaccinated
people may work better
than convalescent plasma
assessing immunity after infection or
vaccination this is one of the major
uses of serology going forward
how long does immunity last we're
getting some clues
about this from people who were infected
a year ago and have been followed
through vaccine studies or
other kinds of clinical studies it's not
known exactly
how can we measure effective immunity
are there
measures of immunity that would predict
whether someone is resistant to
re-infection
or at least resistant to getting ill
requiring hospitalization
are there specific markers of effective
immunity
antibodies to which antigens
of the virus or epitopes so which are
small parts of those antigens
is it to the spike protein which is on
the surface or nuclear capsid protein
and a very abundant protein that
surrounds a nucleic acid inside the
viral particle
t cells these are lymphocytes and this
is how immunity tuberculosis is measured
because the antibody response to tb is
not a very good measurement
a reliable measurement of immunity are
there other markers in their blood
or some combination of these various
markers
and finally how long will immunity need
to be assessed over time
is it going to be forever maybe until
this pandemic resolves and the virus
isn't circulating anymore these are
major questions that we're asked asking
now and i would just mention
that there's a lot of work on
identifying
markers in the blood that might indicate
effective immunization these are
beyond antibodies other kinds of things
that the body produces that might
indicate
effective immunity and also
people are studying the repertoire of
antibodies
and t cells that are in the blood that
might indicate effective immunization
not just the quantities of antibodies
but the actual
ants types of antibodies that are
produced so there's a lot of ongoing
research to try to get
a handle on what are these indicators of
successful
immunity and resistance to reinfection
it's possible that vaccination-induced
immunity will be long-lasting
and some evidence for this is that that
first
sars infection cov1 which happened
again 20 some years ago
nearly 20 years ago they do wane over
time
but the t cell responses remain after 15
years
which might allow someone to mount a
massive a
very quick restoration of immunity in
case they were re-exposed to that virus
problem is of course cov1 is not
circulating anymore so there's no way to
know for sure
the same may be true of coping 19 and
there's indication that infected people
have
in their bone marrow which is where the
cells of the blood are formed plasma
cells
that are sars kobe 2 specific that last
a long time and might provide this
long-lasting protection
a real problem happens though in cancer
patients
and so what happens in hematologic
malignancies which are
leukemia and lymphoma these are cancers
of the blood
that only about half of people
in this study of 67 patients with
hemologic malignancies who've received
either the pfizer or modern messenger
rna vaccines
only half produced significant
antibodies half didn't
46 which might mean that they're not
protected in case they're exposed to the
virus
and there are many studies in many
centers
that indicate through their own
preliminary results
that vaccines may not protect patients
with regan immune systems from cancer
inflammatory bowel disease or other
kinds of
immuno compromising illnesses
in addition a recent study that was the
subject of a lab roots presentation by
dr
hans last week indicate that while
normal controls
mount very nice antibody responses
uh to vaccination
that patients who've received kidney
transplants
have very poor antibody responses upon
vaccination
at 14 28 36 and 58 days post vaccination
and even hemodialysis patients patients
who need to have their blood cleaned
periodically to remove toxins because
they have decreased
kidney function they also do not have
the kind of strong in antibody response
seen in
normal individuals and the reasons for
this are that kidney transplant patients
are on immunosuppressive medic
medications
that keep their immune system from
rejecting their transplanted kidney
and hemodialysis patients part of the
reason you have dialysis
is to remove uric acid and they have
uremia in the blood which actually is
immune inhibits the the quality of the
immune response
there are many other conditions
autoimmune diseases
immune deficient states and
immunosuppressive medications
that many many people take for many
reasons and these
also are impair adaptive immunity
and might prevent someone from becoming
effectively immune
after vaccination and therefore may be
susceptible to this infection
so those are the five major areas
primary diagnosis epidemiology immunity
in immunocompromised people
evaluating plasma and assessing adaptive
immunity after infection or vaccination
that are the focus for a lot of the
current and future serology
i'd like to now turn to discussing the
variation
among vaccines with respect to
prevention of infection
adaptive immunity and effectiveness
against the variants
first prevention of infection or serious
illness
all five major vaccine types
work well messenger rna vaccines by
pfizer and materna
protein subunit vaccine novavax
as an example and viral vector vaccines
by johnson johnson and astrazeneca
there are differences the percentage
protection
might differ here and there but overall
these all
work very well yet preventing
certainly serious illness and death and
also in primary infection
so they all prevent infection and
serious illness in most people
there are a few percent 5 10 15 20
depending on the vaccine that still can
have breakthrough infections but by and
large they work well
they work well because they induce
strong adaptive immunity and i'll talk
about this in a minute what that means
two sars cov2 virus other vaccines are
likely to work well too how well
what remains to be seen and but overall
it's been a huge success one of the
greatest successes of modern medicine
actually is
the rapidity and success of developing
vaccines against
the covid19 virus
how about adaptive immunity
well let's discuss what this means first
this is the specific
immune response that a human body makes
against a pathogen
a virus bacterium any kind of infectious
agent
a vaccine or a foreign body
right it involves both an
antibody response and a cell mediated
response
these are both kinds of immunity two
different arms of the immune system
and they are both part of adaptive
immunity
lymphocytes are the mediators
lymphocytes
produce antibodies and some lymphocytes
produce to this virus neutralizing
antibodies
that basically block the virus from
infecting cells and sort of stop it in
its tracks
neutralizing antibodies are most often
directed
against the spike protein the s antigen
and can be measured by either plaque
reduction or micro
neutralization assays which are
basically in vitro tests
that measure the viruses ability to
infect cells
and if you add serum or plasma
containing neutralizing antibodies it
reduces the viruses ability to infect
those cells and this can
be measured in this in these assays
unfortunately neutralizing antibodies
alone do not seem to provide provide
full protection
from this virus and the evidence for
this is that
as i mentioned earlier convalescent
plasma and monoclonal antibodies
the therapies have been disappointing
cytotoxic t cells this is part of that
cell mediated immunity
they can attack and kill virus-infected
cells
they have t cell receptors that are
specific for viral proteins that are
then
presented on the surface of an infected
cell these
cells recognize those attack and kill
those cells
and they can be specific for many viral
proteins not just that spike protein
but any protein viral protein produced
in those infected cells and there are
many
just to review a few of these proteins
this is the sars covi genome coe one or
two there's
basically the same genome and they
produce a number of proteins
this one's called orf-1a spike
membrane protein nucleocapsid protein
and e antigen and these are the four
major proteins s e m and n found in the
viral particle
however in an infected cell the virus
also produces all these other proteins
that are encoded by all these other
genes
and all of them actually potentially
induce
an adaptive immune response so adaptive
immunity can develop against any and
all viral antigens external and internal
to the virus and
even to proteins not found in the mature
viral particles that are
potentially ways that we can induce
these cytotoxic t cells to kill
viral infected cells the
s spike protein is most often used for
vaccination it's used in all of those
vaccines i mentioned on the slide a few
slides ago and
n are most often used to measure
antibodies to the virus
this is just because manufacturers just
chose these two major antigens
over a year ago to develop their initial
serologic tests
n is used to detect infection
in people who've been vaccinated with
spike protein
the reason is such a person will make
antibodies to spike
that will not allow spike itself to
distinguish between a vaccinated
and a vaccinated infected person they
both
types of people make antibodies to spike
but the
n antigen can be used in those patients
to distinguish
vaccination from infections
there are some differences in the
immunity induced by the different
vaccines
it's not really known whether those
differences matter yet
again this is all new territory this
infection's only been around for a year
and a half and we're
still learning a lot about it as every
day
passes the vaccines do appear to provide
effective immunity against
the variants this is likely because each
vaccine
induces a very strong immune response
against
many proteins many viral proteins so
it's poly specific
and many antibodies and t cells reactive
against each viral protein
so polyclonal this is the way we make
immunity to
any infection and so this is in this
case why the vaccines appear
to provide effective immunity against
the variants because the variants
might differ in their protein sequences
from time to time but the vast majority
of antigens and epitopes small parts of
those antigens
are are going to be the same across all
variants
and so this is why immunity despite
protein
works very well even across variants
and it's important to understand that
both antibodies and t
cells are important in our fight against
many infections including this one
what about effectiveness against the
variants well
one of the hallmark features of viruses
is that they mutate they mutate because
the enzymes that replicate the viral
nucleic acid the viral genome are make
mistakes
and those mutations then occur at random
throughout the entire viral genome
some of those mutations kill the virus
they
inactivate a protein it's essential for
the virus and those mutants don't
survive and they're eliminated from the
population we never see them
in population studies but some give the
virus an advantage in infectivity
they can either help a virus invade
cells
divide faster survive in respiratory
droplets there are lots of ways
that changes in protein sequence can
help a virus to be
a better spreader and that's what it's
all about
we talk about viral variants increasing
and decreasing in frequency
is because they have an advantage in
spreading that's the only thing that
matters not whether they kill people
but whether they can spread better some
of the mutations are in the spike
protein
that's this viral surface protein that
binds to the host
receptor that initiates the invasion
process that's called
ace2 is the name of it and
scientists have been sequencing viral
isolates from around the world there
have been hundreds of thousands of
sequences
determined over time beginning
way back in wuhan china
in late 2019 and over the
months you can see the
acquisition of new variant sequences
through following all these little
lines here are different viral types
having different mutations
so this is after april of last year
june august october december
february april up to june of today
so there's been a huge number of new
variants including
some that have not varied too much since
the original wuhan strain
back in at the end of 2019.
so the number of variant sites per
virus isolate are small but they're
measurable they're measurable because we
can sequence the viral genomes
and then follow them epidemiologically
over time
so these variants of concern
or variances people call them just
generically
spread through populations and they have
molecular features that facilitate
their spread at the moment
there are five that have been labeled by
the who alpha beta gamma delta
epsilon that previously refer to
variant names as followed where their
initial expansion occurred in the united
kingdom
south africa brazil india and california
and by tracking these over time you can
see
at least at the moment that the b117
that's that
alpha the one that originally initiated
in the united kingdom
is the dominant form with about 70
percent
you can see that even better over here
70 percent of
all the current isolates are of that
type
but i want to point out that the delta
variant this is the one from india is
currently
2.7 percent this little tiny
uh dark red one here and that was not
even
point one percent even a few months ago
so
over time uh these variants can
increase or decrease in their prevalence
in this case in the united states
so some spike proteins mutations allow
the virus to enter cells more
efficiently we're talking about how they
work
you know what what is it about the
variants that make them
expand and some variants
contain other proteins
that are produced in the infected cell
in this case
or 6 and or 9b that interfere with host
immunity and are expressed at higher
levels in some variants
so it's a combination of specific
protein mutations
that allow the virus to do its thing
better and
viral proteins that interfere with our
ability to fight the infection that
seems to be how they can work
how well do the vaccines protect against
the variants very well
there have been many papers and this is
just one for example
that shows that the pfizer
vaccine protects against the
617 which is the delta from india
that initially arose in india and the
351
variant which is the one from south
africa so
the pfizer and modern vaccines were
generated against the sequence
originally found in wuhan china
but they seem to work very well against
these variants as well and the same
thing is
true of other vaccines there are however
occasional breakthrough infections and
that's
5 10 15 of people can still acquire
infection
and in some cases they can acquire
infection
even though they've had very high levels
of antibodies
they get very high virus upon infection
so the antibodies were present before
infection virus gets to the high very
high levels high viremia it's called
during infection and they can get very
sick and even require hospitalization
most people with breakthrough infections
are either asymptomatic or have mild
symptoms though so
robust adaptive humeral and cellular
immunity develops after vaccination
that's why it works
and it is possible that using two
different vaccine types might have some
advantage
and there's a lot of research going on
now where for example
uh initially vaccinating with a pfizer
vaccine but then boosting
with an astrazeneca might give even
stronger immunity
than just vaccinating and boosting with
the single
vaccine type it's also possible
that we might induce long-term immunity
from vaccination or
for people who've been infected and
recover for infection
and there's a lot of research on this
issue because it's a major question of
whether we're going to need booster
shots or not
and that's something that we'll learn
more about over the next six months
of course it's possible and we hope that
over
the next months and years that this
virus will not be in circulation
and maybe we won't even need to be
following this but for right now since
that's a big unknown we need to
basically operate with the idea that we
will need to be
surveilling for this virus for quite a
long time to come
the next section is to understand the
latest innovations
in serology assay design and that is to
try
to produce a natural form of that spike
protein which is trimeric form
as a capture antigen so
this is where the spike receptor binding
domain
receptor binding domain binds to the
host h2 receptor so this is
on the host cell this is on the virus
this binding interaction
is what we're trying to target
neutralizing antibodies can block it
that's the basis for antibody therapy
and the plasma therapy
and you can theoretically try to block
it from this side or from this side so
people are doing research
to try to use h2 receptor blockers
to inhibit the virus viral entry
the spike protein itself has is a long
protein with lots of parts
the receptor binding domain shown here
is what a lot of people focus on for the
development
of neutralizing antibodies but this
n-terminal domain
is also very important so these two
domains are important here antibodies
are produced during natural infection or
to vaccination to both rbd
and ntd and to other parts of the viral
spike protein as well
the viral spike protein shown in this
electron micrograph
is actually a trimer it's three
identical types of proteins
shown here in falsely colored blue green
and red
that come together to make a trimer
they're sort of all folded onto each
other to make a three-part
protein this is the natural form of this
viral protein
so despite protemer one copy of this
was produced either in its form
with the so-called s1 and s2 domains
comprising a serology test produced by
diasoren
called s1s2 the receptor binding domain
which is a key part for that binding to
the ace2 receptor
is the protein that's produced by a
number of other
corporations and the new one produced by
diasaurin at the moment there may be
other companies producing this in the
future
has been engineered to hold together as
a trimer the natural form of the protein
form shown here and the advantage of
that
may be that antibodies to the receptor
binding domain
bind to all three of these types of
antigen
the n-terminal domain which is also
found here and found in the dsor and s1
s2
and the trimeric form can also initiate
antibodies
that can bind to them but there are
other
antibodies that bind to the interface
between protomers
the three protomers the interface
between the blue and the green
the red and the green etc and those
also can be used for serology
there have been a recent there's a
recent study in
uh by benelli that compared
that diasaur and trimeric s with the rbd
tests by siemens and beckman and
basically what they found
is that in the case of siemens up on top
and beckman down below
that in most cases the test results are
the same
positive in both semen and diasoren
negative in both siemens and diosora
positive in both beckmann and diasorn
negative in both
beckmann diazo however so these are
concordant results
however there are some discordant
results these are results like these 62
which are
positive by the dsr and trimeric protein
that are negative by the siemens rbd
test this one and likewise six that are
negative
by dslr that are positive by cenas
and the same thing is true down here
with the beckman
and so what benelli did is he basically
analyzed those discordant samples
by that micro neutralization assay which
directly detects the ability of the
sample to interfere with viral
entry to a host cell and what you can
see is if you take the six
samples that were positive on the
centaur
and the 62 that were negative in the
centaur and look at the neutralization
titers
and conversely take those same samples
that were positive by dsor and the 62
and the six that were negative you'll
see that
two out of the six that were positive
both by rbd and
neutralization it's only two out of six
whereas 60 out of 62 were positive by
both the trimeric s
and the micro neutralization
so that indicates and i'll discuss this
shortly that maybe the trimeric has a
little
better greater sensitivity than the rbd
alone
and that's something that time will tell
but it seems from this study to be very
clear
the other question relates to what
happens after vaccination
so this anti-s by the trimeric s
antigen can be easily used to detect
infection and in fact at
the time of the first dose of vaccines
and before the vaccine has been given
patients are negative after dose
one plus 21 days three weeks after the
first dose
uh essentially everyone's positive and
has measurable titers
using the w.h.o the new uh standard
called binding uh antibody units
and then after three weeks after the
second dose the titers are way up in the
4
000 range so these are uninfected people
15 people who have been previously
infected were also
included in the study at the time of
dose one before any vaccine
they were all positive because they've
been infected
and what's interesting is that their
viral loads are 131
bau per mil but after dose one
and two you can see that it's 12 000
18 000 and then it drops down here 120
days
later but basically the titers in these
15 people who are infected recovered
are much higher than is ever observed
in the patients who've never been
infected before
so it seems that this trimeric gas has a
very
large dynamic range for infection
for detecting antibodies so these are my
preliminary thoughts about this trimeric
acid has a very large dynamic range
it appears to be more sensitive than the
other rbd assays as evidenced by
those discord discordant results that
are positive by diaspora and trimeric s
that negative by siemens almost
are all positive by that micro
neutralization assay
and that greater dynamic range and
sensitivity may be important for
assessing immunity over time
so let me conclude sars kobe 2 is a
perfect
virus the vaccines work as well as could
possibly be
imagined there is a race now between
vaccination and spread
with a handful of variants of concern
leading the spread
we're especially concerned about
sub-saharan africa and india as well
it's not known how long immunity
from either infection and recovery or
vaccination will protect a person from
re-exposure
and the recent results suggest that it
may be long-lasting but nobody knows for
sure
and protection also appears to extend to
variance
there is no gold standard for measuring
effective immunity but
people are using serology as the easiest
and most
uh accurate and sensitive and specific
way at the moment
and viral neutralization which is
terrific but it's not really practical
to apply to large numbers of samples
there may be other markers in kit
indicating resistance
will we need these are unanswered
questions will we need a booster
nobody knows for sure why do some people
have breakthrough infections
despite having high levels of antibodies
that five percent
ten percent depending on the vaccine
will all people need serologic follow-up
after vaccination or are there special
populations immunocompromised people
healthcare workers
will sars cov2 stop circulating at some
point so this is all moot we're
not going to worry about this five years
ten years from now maybe sooner
and it is very likely that serology will
be the best and easiest way to assess
immunity
for many of the purposes discussed uh
today
and finally it's important that the
serologic test
be sensitive enough to detect waning igg
levels over time
and the trimeric s protein may provide
this
advantage over current tests
thank you all for your attention and
we are hopeful that this pandemic will
come to an end soon
and we can all return throughout the
globe to our normal lives
thank you dr engman for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started okay
our first question is
where does severology testing fit in a
post-vaccine world
well uh thank you all for uh your
attention and thanks for that first
question
that is the big question uh i think that
uh while many people look for
all kinds of biomarkers for effective
immunization or effective immunity due
to
infection and recovery serology
is very likely to be what people will
be looking toward long term for
measuring the presence of antibodies
that can protect
against infection and also those
antibodies
indicate the presence of underlying t
cell responses
that are also important for killing
infected cells
there's a lot of history of that kind of
approach
from other kinds of vaccines and
infections that we face
measles month rubella hepatitis where we
receive vaccines
and at least in the healthcare community
the titers of those antibodies are
checked over time to be sure that those
childhood immunizations
uh still have produced uh circulating
antibodies that will prevent
someone from re getting infected by
measles virus for example
so i think that over time serology will
show
itself to be a very durable way of
measuring
effective immunity to infection but
again
only time will tell and especially when
people
uh a small number of people as long as
the virus persists and the circulating
become infected then studies of those
people will be important to determine
whether the
presence of antibodies detected by
serology correlates
with either protection or lack of
protection and so that's
what i see is the future of serology
thank you dr engman our next question
we get lots of questions from staff
concerning why they should get the
vaccination when they are testing
positive on antibody tests from previous
infection
can you please explain the overall
benefits and why
well i think that as time goes on
people are realizing that the titers
of antibodies and perhaps even you know
there aren't
as many studies being done on the
cellular immune responses
but they're certainly much higher
after vaccinating someone who even
though they've recovered from infection
and have
measurable anti-cova-19 viral antibody
so the levels of immunity induced by
vaccination are much higher
than those induced by infection recovery
formally nobody's proven that having
lower levels or higher levels of
antibodies provide different levels of
protection so it really isn't known and
i think that is why the recommendation
has been since the onset
that even though someone has been
infected that they go ahead and receive
the vaccine because it is not known yet
whether uh the levels of immunity
uh induced by infection in recovery
uh are protective as well as
the immunity induced by the virus uh
by vaccination i should mention though
that the immunity induced by
infection and recovery is against
many proteins of the virus whereas the
immunity induced by vaccination is
against
only the protein used in the vaccine i
actually misspoke a little bit uh
halfway through the presentation about
the kinds of immunity generated if you
are vaccinated with a spike vaccine
you're only going to make immunity to
spike you there's no nuclear capsid or
other any other protein in the vaccine
so you will not be immune to those
proteins so
i think that only time will tell whether
the lower levels of measurable
antibodies from infection recovery
are adequate in protecting someone and
over what period of time people don't
know either
thank you dr engman our next question is
oh let me find it do you see a medical
value to bridge b cell response
igg or total ig and t-cell response to
have a more accurate interpretation
and to develop the algorithm accordingly
i certainly believe that from a
research side that it's very important
to do those studies because
i think that the quality rather than
beyond the quantity of antibodies
whether they're igg
leon there are some people who have igm
levels that initial antibody that comes
up that persist
longer than in other people and uh
it's not known whether that reflects any
aspect of immunity that might be
beneficial
and certainly looking at the cellular
responses
in a research way is important because
that's how we understand
what are the parameters for effective
immunity
on a practical level though to apply
that to a large number of people
there are certainly t-cell assays
that measure cellular immunity that are
used every day to measure immunity to
mycobacterium tuberculosis the so-called
quantiferon
assay that is applied to every
healthcare worker and
certainly in the western world as a
measure of immunity
or exposure to tb that could be adapted
for uh kovi too so
uh i think that on a research level
all that will be going on that's going
on right now
but to apply that to a larger population
is a big unknown question and of course
the biggest question of all is
if vaccination is really rolled out to
the world like
we have the ability to do it we can make
these vaccines we can deliver them
perhaps we'll be able to reduce this
virus to the point that it's no longer a
threat
and we won't need to be concerned about
that but that's
just conjecture on my part it's wishful
thinking of course
[Music]
thank you again dr engman our next
question
is there a mortality difference
associated with mutant subtypes
uh there is uh there are differences in
mortality but they're not
they're not very large it's not like the
delta variant has a 50
mortality rate when people talk about a
3 percent mortality versus a
four percent mortality well that's a
thirty percent increase four percent
versus three percent
but it's still lowish so i think that
there may be measurable differences the
studies generally
because the number of patients is still
fairly small and people aren't doing
extensive studies on
every patient who does succumb to this
infection
it's really not known what the
significance
for large populations is of the small
but measurable differences in mortality
induced by one variant or another
remember the virus doesn't care whether
it kills people or not all
and in fact it doesn't care at all it's
just going along
its happy way spreading faster if it can
replicate and persist and all those
other things that make
spread easier for that variant than for
other variants that's how it increases
in this prevalence in a population
thank you dr ingman next question here
some literatures are citing the
prevalence of delta variant to 10
in the usa and roughly up to 60 in the
uk
do you agree
well i think that the um
you'd have to look at the individual
studies and the numbers of
people and samples involved in that and
to make a decision
in general the studies that are
published in peer-reviewed literature
and are reviewed by experts have already
been through that kind of scrutiny and
statistical analysis and any
differences that are large differences
between
study outcomes are tend
to be due to differences in the
populations studied
and rather than methodology
i will say though that for many
infectious diseases
there are differences based on the
human genetic background immunogenetic
background in some cases
where some populations may be more
susceptible
of uh to a particular infection and
others more naturally resistant
to infection and so there could be some
of that going on to
on the host side host immunogenetic
variation and susceptibility and
resistance
resistance to this virus that could uh
be partly responsible for different
outcomes of those kinds of studies
that's a good question
thank you dr engman our next question
what are the advantages of the trimeric
s antigen
as a capture antigen for serology
testing
remember that this infection has only
been with us
for a year and a half and
all the major companies academic labs
rushed to try to find the best antigens
to use
for serology for vaccine studies etc
they tend for serology to focus on
the s antigen and n the nucleocapsid and
spike proteins
because those turned out in very early
studies to induce the highest levels of
antibodies even though nucleocapsids not
on the surface of the
viral particle it's very abundant in the
viral particle and induces very strong
antibody and t cell responses
for practical manufacturing reasons and
others every company has its own reason
for choosing either rbd
or s1 f2 or now trimeric s
it was easy to produce rbd it's a small
fraction of the s antigen it can be
produced
very quickly in large amounts and
infected people tend to have antibodies
against rbd so it was an effective
way to measure where the trimeric
uh has an advantage over both rbd and
the predecessor
in dsorin company the s1f2 is that it
has lots
more epitopes lots more parts of that
protein
than the small rbd does so in theory
it can capture more antibodies produced
by
an infected or vaccinated person and
that's probably responsible for why it's
more sensitive
at least in that benelli paper to rbd
um so i think that's the reason why
there's some advantage that it's more
sensitive if
it's important to measure lowish
amounts of antibody maybe 10 12 months
after vaccination
as antibodies wane over time
to the the the patient's sample will
still be
positive uh whereas the rbd might be
negative and might lead someone to
receive a booster shot unnecessarily
again though i would emphasize that
nobody has correlated
or attempted to yet the levels of
antibodies the quantity
of anti-antibodies and
resistance to or susceptibility to
future infection
so but so we're in uncharted territory
but these are theoretical arguments for
using an antigen that has
greater sensitivity which the trimeric s
appears to from that study by benelli
well
thank you dr engman we are out of time
for questions today
um do you have any final comments for
the audience
um i would only con
saying that it's just been remarkable i
mean if uh
when i was thinking about this disease
i've been uh
working on this just like many people in
the audience for a year and a half
back in april may of last year i never
thought it would be
continuing beyond last fall but here we
are
and even though lots of the vaccinated
world is going on its merry way
we're still losing ten thousand maybe
it's down to eight thousand now
people a day this is not gone and um
i think that with vigilance and with
continued advances in health care
diagnostics and treatments
uh we're hopeful that a year from now we
won't be having the same kind of
lab roots seminar necessary anymore
thank you
well thank you again dr david eggman for
your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank labrus
and our sponsor dia soron for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye